good morning Hank it's Wednesday
September 7 today I'm going to introduce
you to everything I find interesting
about the Great Gatsby without massive
spoilers it's gonna take a few minutes
but I'm going to go as quickly as I can
because life is fleeting is one of the
themes at the Great Gatsby so right at
the beginning of the second chapter of
cat food we get two of the great
metaphors in American literature first
the Valley of Ashes the narrator Nick
writes about this huge Valley of Ashes
outside of Manhattan this was real and
in 1922 there was this like ever-growing
depository of the burned wastes of
people who lived in and around New York
and in the novel George Wilson this gas
station owner lives in the Valley of
Ashes with his wife Myrtle with whom Tom
Buchanan is having an affair anyone
who's read even five pages of the Great
Gatsby will no doubt remember Tom
Buchanan is one of the world's least
likable people yeah so right there in
the Valley of Ashes there are also the
eyes of dr. TJ eckleburg whose irises
are like one yard high they're just
these disembodied unblinking eyes that
see everything below them like they
don't have arms to catch you or legs to
chase you down they can't punish you or
kill you but dr. TJ eckleburg eyes see
everything but more than in a minute so
Tom and his mistress and her sister and
Nick and his random other couple end up
in an apartment in New York just getting
drunk and utilizing servants and
creating more ashes for the valley and
generally having like the worst time
ever one of the crazy things about The
Great Gatsby is there's always some
debaucherous party going on and no one
is ever having any fun like everybody in
that room just wants more money and more
class and they want to like find a way
to get a better life except for Tom
Buchanan who has what they all want
except that Tom Buchanan is like an
unbearable Tom Buchanan makes
Paris Hilton look like charming and
grounded and that's one of the
criticisms you hear about The Great
Gatsby that no one in the book is
likable I don't think that's fair to
Gatsby or to Nick or in to a certain
extent I don't think it's fair to Daisy
but more importantly I don't know where
people got the idea that characters and
books are supposed to be likeable books
are not in the business of creating
merely likable characters with whom you
can have some simple identification
books are in the business of creating
great stories that make your brain go
all like garbage your mom bah bah sorry
I spend all my time with a baby right so
shortly after that horrible party we go
to an awesome party at Gatsby's house I
mean there's still a lot of stuff being
created for the Valley of Ashes
but at least Gatsby's party has Gatsby
and even though Gatsby has this
incredibly annoying habit of saying old
sport all the time as a way of trying to
sound upper-crusty he's a pretty
charming guy he has a smile that makes
you feel that he is irresistible
prejudiced in your favor
to quote Nick but the one thing we know
about Gatsby for much of the book is
that no one knows anything about him
like there's thought that he might be a
bootlegger or a killer or owned a chain
of drugstores no one really seems to
know even though everyone's at his
parties drinking his booze running
around his mansion I should mention that
first party at Gatsby's house also
contains the greatest drunk driving
scene in the history of American
literature in which a drunk guy gets in
an accident like three seconds after
getting in his car and even though the
wheel has fallen off of a car he keeps
trying to drive it and I think at least
in the novel that had become the
American dream by the 1920s the dream
was to they don't have a leisurely and
debaucherous life where you had enough
money to buy fancy new cars and enough
whiskey to crash them but we weren't
pretty quickly that Gatsby isn't like
the people who go to his parties he
hasn't acquired like wealth and social
status so that he can enjoy them he
doesn't drink it as he repeatedly points
out to Nick he's never even used his own
pool he's worked to get this money and
build this social status because he is
in love with a woman who lives across
the bay whose dock has a green light at
the end of it and that woman is Daisy
Buchanan Tom Buchanan's wife Daisy and
gasps we had fallen in love years before
but then Gatsby went off to war and she
got married and now she goes across the
bay in the green light and it just wants
to reach it so he asks Nick to
manufacture a reunion all right and at
that reunion everything is yellow like
Gatsby's car is yellow and Gatsby's tie
is yellow and Daisy Buchanan's dress
buttons are yellow at one point Nick who
is third-wheeling at big time at this
reunion describes the smell of flowers
as pale gold it's not an accident in
this very chapter Nick refers to the
green light at the end of Daisy's dock
that Gatsby's always looking out at and
reaching for as an enchanted object and
that seems to me a reasonably good
definition of symbolism symbols are
enchanted objects and yellow or gold is
an enchanted color in this novel but not
just in this novel but also like in our
lives like golden opportunities or a
golden age or golden youth God knows the
characters in this novel weren't the
first people to ever conflate wealth and
beauty but what
the interesting questions in The Great
Gatsby is whether Gatsby really loves
Daisy or if he loves her because she's
golden you know because as he once
famously says her voice is full of money
Gatsby hasn't come by his money honestly
he has no class or family background Tom
Buchanan calls him mr. nobody from
nowhere and maybe Gatsby can never be
mr. somebody from somewhere but Daisy
Buchanan would certainly help with her
family connections and her legitimate
money we see this tomb in the book
flashes back to the Midwest when Gatsby
and Daisy first fall in love his Gatsby
falling in love with Daisy or with her
family's mansion but regardless before
Daisy and Gatsby can run off into the
golden sunset there's the small matter
of her being married to Tom and the
fascinating thing is that by the novel's
climax it's not enough - Gatsby that
Daisy loves him he needs Daisy to say I
never loved Tom I only ever loved you
because for Gatsby it's not enough to
get Daisy back he has to get the feeling
he first had when they fell in love back
that feeling of purity and innocence he
has to reclaim his past and that dream
or more specifically the foul dust that
trails in the wake of it is more than
about two characters in a novel it is
the American dream and the world's dream
there will never be enough money and
fame and love for us in this world
because every time we get what we
thought we wanted we realize that we
want more because what we really want is
to go back in time to someplace when we
felt safe some time before we discovered
violence and corruption when we were
happy and pure and innocent we want to
go to the Golden Age but for Gatsby the
relentless pursuit of that dream leads
to only more violence and corruption
until there's this penultimate moment of
violence that is witnessed by the eyes
of dr. TJ eckleburg and then Gatsby
finally gets to use his pool Hank the
last chapter the Great Gatsby is to me
one of the saddest passages in American
literature it shows how muddied
innocence and guilt are and it shows the
vast and intractable unfairness of this
society that was supposedly founded on
equality at one point nipper called
people who would go to those great
parties and sneer most bitterly at
Gatsby on the courage of Gatsby's liquor
let me submit to you that those of us
who would sneer at Gatsby do so on the
courage of his liquor because we all
share his ambition we all believed in
that green light that has long eluded us
that if we can only run faster stretch
out our arms farther than one fine
morning and still the foul dust trails
in the wake of those dreams Hank I have
non rhetorical questions for you today
which we must discuss here in comments
because your pants have been act first
to what extent do you think Gatsby is a
hero I mean I know he's the titular
character of the novel but to what
extent do you think that his quest is
heroic and secondly is your quest heroic
Hank I'll see you on Friday